so why did i do that
so here i discovered a
few months ago that the box for which
i work there but namco pharma was
pouring out liters and liters of
contaminated liquid here in the nièvre
me my job is to enforce
the safety standards clearly this
is not the case suddenly I noted them
in my report
but it did not rain but it is quite
simple you will speak to your boss there he
tells you that he transmits the  'info we
ask you to reva him and for my defense
the union covers the costs or the more you
doubt or the more were quickly and we end
up telling you that you are more competent
clearly they told me to shut up I was
losing my job  I can't stay like
that and say nothing by that I don't know I
know it's risky we don't take it that
you let me tell you my intention is
that Mrs. confirms respect
safety standards that's all quote me
part  when I have nothing to gain
in this it's confirmed I'm
fired for gross negligence  ve
they searched and they took
all my computer equipment lost
I don't know how I'm going to do it I
'm going to have to pay colossal damages all my life
so I don't know then why I
did this but he  I had to tell the
truth so that people know I can't
stay anyway say nothing
here